dans la vie j'ai le choix de me dire ce
verre est à moitié vide ou allons plus
loin qu à moitié plein je peux aussi
m'intéresser à son précieux contenu et
me demander qu'est-ce que je peux faire
avec
je peux le boire je peut l'offrir
je peux l'utiliser pour arroser une
plante point c ou pour cuisiner être
positif et le tremplin avec lequel nous
pouvons choisir d'aller plus loin
choisir d'agir rappelez-vous du bo le
petit éléphant il est né avec des
oreilles trop longue qui le faisait
trébucher
qu'est ce qu'il pouvait faire avec lui a
appris à vous les autres fois je ne me
rendais pas compte que j'avais de l'eau
dans mon verre je trouve être les
progrès de mes autres enfants étaient
normaux c'était presque un dû cela se
faisait tout seul mais quand nicolas mon
quatrième fils aîné j'ai vu tout de
suite qu'il y avait un souci pas de
contact oculaire
ils ne réclamaient même pas à manger il
était dans un état de légumes qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec
j'ai décidé de faire tout mon possible
pour l'aider à progresser à six mois un
grand spécialiste confirme le diagnostic
est infirme que nicolas ne pourra jamais
marcher jamais parlé et qu'il restera un
légume toute sa vie
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec je le
considère comme un défi et j'aime les
défis
plus c'est difficile plus je suis
attirée vous avez remarqué que j'ai dit
défi et non problème
quelle est la connotation de ce mot
quand on entend problème
c'est souvent une catastrophe les
enfants entendent leurs parents parler
de problème avec une mine accablé et
après on s'étonne qu'il se bloque
quand il voit le mot problèmes à l'école
bon alors pour moi les difficultés de
nicolas était un défi à surmonter
non un problème mais ce dont je n'avais
aucune idée
c'était l'ampleur de ce défi
heureusement mark twain aller dit il ne
savait pas que c'était impossible alors
ils l'ont fait je ne savais pas que
c'était impossible alors je les fais
j'ai d'abord fait la différence entre
diagnostiques et pronostiques
on ne peut pas changer un diagnostic
mais le pronostic
oui et j'ai choisi de ne pas croire aux
pronostics se sont défavorables ensuite
premiers pronostics
il ne pourra jamais marcher qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec
je vais lui apprendre j'ai des composés
toutes les étapes en famille nous
l'avons appris à bouger ses bras et ses
jambes a musclé son dos en poussant sur
ses jambes à se retourner à s'asseoir à
ramper sur un plan incliné à ramper sur
un sol horizontale à marcher à quatre
pattes puis à faire un pas j'ai ainsi
appris à me fixer des bus et pour chaque
but des objectifs précis à atteindre est
encore mieux
vous n'imaginez pas la joie que j'avais
pour chaque objectif atteint et du coup
je me réjouissais davantage pour tous
les progrès de mes autres enfants
j'ai appris à me réjouir de chats
petites choses qui m'entourent d'avoir
de la gratitude pour tous ceux qui
m'entourent et ressentir la gratitude
c'est le secret du bonheur
deuxième pronostics qui ne pourra jamais
parler effectivement à quatre ans
nicolas ne savait pas répéter le son a
aucune orthophoniste dans les environs
ne se sentait compétente pour le prendre
j'aurais pu me dire que c'est à cause de
son handicap qu'il n'arrivait pas à
sortir de son intelligible mais chercher
des excuses
c'est baisser les bras agir c'est
trouver des moyens
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
j'ai trouvé une orthophoniste à 90
kilomètres de chez nous qui lui a appris
à dire d'abord moto puis papa et maman
vous imaginer ma joie
il ya toujours des moyens il suffit de
les trouver
je me suis ensuite formé au marathon qui
utilisent la langue des signes est il
alors enfin compris que les sons qu'il
entendait avait du sens
puis c'est la lecture apprises grâce à
la méthode de ma mère qui lui a permis
de parler mais parallèlement à ses
progrès physiques
nicolas adorait les jeux stéréotypés ils
pouvaient allumer éteindre allumé et
aime allumer éteindre la lumière pendant
des heures dans un centre où il allait
il s'amusait à vider à verre dans un
autre pendant des heures des jours des
semaines une professionnelle de là bas
m'a dit qu'il en avait sûrement besoin
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec je me
suis demandé quel besoin
et là j'ai eu l'idée du siècle enfin
pour mon enfant je pense aussi pour tous
ceux qui ont aidé attitude autistique
je me suis dit qu'ils avaient besoin
d'apprendre quelque chose de son
expérience
et là je lui ai appris plein vide et les
notions de plus moins autant moitié il
m'a regardée et c'était fini il n'a plus
jamais joué à ce jeu
nous aussi nous réitérons des
expériences nous faisons des erreurs
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons compris
quelque chose
heureusement ce grand spécialiste nous
avait dit que nicolas n'irait jamais à
l'école qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
j'ai demandé à ce qu'ils aillent à 5 ans
ils allaient deux heures par semaine à
l'école maternelle
pourquoi un enfant en difficulté at il
besoin de moins d'heures de scolarité
d'un enfant qui fonctionne bien
je n'ai toujours pas compris cette
logique encore en vigueur aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'explique un jour
ils s'amusaient et s'appliquait à
colorier un dessin alors que la
maîtresse voulait me parler
elle me dit que nicolas ne comprenez
rien aux consignes et en plus elle
constatait qu'il était moins compétents
que ses élèves de deux ans et alors là
nicolas a gribouillé furieusement son
dessin et à froisser sa page qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec
j'ai compris quelque chose de capital
imaginez vous dans la peau d'un enfant
un adulte vous dit tu es incapable
qu'est ce que cela vous fait verbe être
indique une identité
si on dit un enfant il était capable
cette étiquette va lui coller à la peau
cette incapacité va alors faire partie
de son être profond et cette étiquette
interdit le changement cela le programme
il va se dire qu'il est comme ça qui ne
veut pas changer
imaginez le mal que cela fait lorsqu'un
enfant en temps il est méchant
il est insupportable il est timide
imaginez le mal que cela fait lorsqu'il
devient un adulte
parce qu'ils se le répète ne vous êtes
vous jamais dit je suis bête pour vous
entraîner à ne plus mettre d'étiquette
commencer par ne plus en maître sur vous
même à la fin de l'année la maîtresse
m'a avoué que des professionnels lui
avait dit de ne pas se fatiguer avec
nicolas puisque de toute façon il na
prendrai jamais à lire écrire compter
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
j'ai compris que si on ne croit pas en
un enfant surtout lorsqu'il est fragile
il ne trouvera pas les ressources en lui
seul a d'ailleurs été démontrée par aux
hôtels & jacobson avec l'effet pygmalion
rappelez vous d'une bo il a appris à
voler parce que les corbeaux croyait
qu'il pouvait le faire
j'ai appris à voir le potentiel à
l'intérieur des personnes j'ai appris à
croire en leurs capacités
et lorsque les personnes ressentent la
fois qu'on a en elle
elles font des miracles rappelez vous
que la maîtresse avait dit que nos
colonnes comprenez rien aux consignes
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
j'avais besoin de comprendre pourquoi
afin de pouvoir l'aider
ils entendaient puisqu'il avait été
opéré pour sa surdité à quatre ans mais
nicolas n'écoutait pas il lisait sur les
lèvres et il avait une grande myopie
donc si la maîtresse était à plus de
deux mètres
il ne pouvait comprendre ce qu'elle
disait j'ai alors appris à rechercher
les vraies raisons d'une difficulté à ne
pas rester dans l'apparence à 6 ans
nicolas est éjecté du système scolaire
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec génial
de toute manière il a seulement appris
dans son école qu'il était incapable à
l'époque j'enseignais des terminales
scientifiques et je me retrouvais avec
un enfant
qu'il ne savait pas la différence entre
2 et 3 quel beau défi j'ai alors appris
à méditer pour trouver des moyens
j'ai trouvé une méthode génial pour
comprendre le nombre et les opérations
qui profitent encore à beaucoup
d'enfants aujourd'hui à 7 ans nicolas et
même rejeté de l'éducation spécialisée
heureusement c'est qu'il avait besoin
d'un autre chemin nous avons décidé de
scolariser à la maison ne croyez pas que
c'était facile pour moi parce que
j'étais enseignante
pour moi tout devait aller vite à 4 ans
je savais lire
à 16 ans j'ai eu mon bac à 18 ans je me
suis marié à 19 ans j'ai eu mon premier
enfant
à 20 ans j'ai une maîtrise et le capes
de mathématiques
à 21 ans le capes pratiques et
l'agrégation de mathématiques
rien à voir avec l'enseignement d'un
enfant en difficulté extrême qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec
j'ai alors appris la patience j'ai
appris à décortiquer chaque
apprentissage je cherchais à savoir à
quel niveau
nicolas était pour l'élever plus haut
c'est ainsi qu'on devrait considérer
tous les élèves non ils sont là pour
être est élevé et quand un enfant a trop
de difficulté qui ne comprend pas que
fait-on on peut se dire qu'il n'a qu'à
travailler ou pire qu'il est incapable
je choisis de me dire qu'est ce que je
vais faire avec et là je considère que
c'est ma responsabilité c'est moi qui
dois trouver comment l'enseigner et je
cherche alors différentes stratégies
jusqu'à ce qu'ils comprennent
j'ai donc continué à enseigner nicolas
mais à ses 10 ans j'avais l'impression
qu'il n'avançait plus dans sa
compréhension
je cherchais les processus nécessaires à
l'apprentissage et je me sentais bloqués
qu'est ce que je vais faire
je suis alors parti seul en camping-car
près d'amsterdam à une formation
feuerstein et j'ai notamment découvert
les 29 fonctions cognitives et cela a
été une révélation
ce sont les briques de base du
raisonnement si vous construisez une
maison sans fondations que se passe-t-il
elle ne tient pas de même pour pouvoir
construire bien un apprentissage
on a besoin que les fonctions cognitives
soit correctement en place
j'ai amélioré leur présentation pour
qu'elle soit accessible même aux enfants
c'est un outil merveilleux pour
comprendre l'origine des difficultés
elles ont même aidé mais quatre autres
enfants qui étaient précoces un enfant
précoce fonctionne tellement vite qu'il
ne sais même pas comment il a retrouvé
un résultat il ne sait même pas comment
il a fait pour réfléchir et souvent un
enfant précoce et en échec scolaire
parce que si le résultat ne vient pas
tout de suite il se bloque
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec je leur
a appris à décortiquer leur raisonnement
pour pouvoir réussir leurs études et
leur vie j'ai alors regardé autour de
moi et j'ai vu que les autres enfants
était loin de nicolas nicolas n'était
pas avec les autres enfants parce qu'il
en avait peur il le gardait une marge de
sécurité de deux mètres qu'est ce que je
vais faire avec
j'en ai parlé au maître d'école de notre
village est il alors proposé de former
ses élèves à l'autisme
ils ont alors cherché des stratégies
pour approcher et intégrée nicolas
cette année passée dans ce ciel 2 a été
sa plus belle année de scolarité dans la
cour de récréation et se laisser
approcher touchés et avaient beaucoup
d'amis j'ai appris que grâce à la bonne
volonté d'un enseignant à la
connaissance et à la préparation
il peut y avoir des miracles j'ai vu
alors d'autres enfants autour de moi
qu'il y avait des difficultés
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec dans
une association que j'avais créé nous
les avons aidés à surmonter leurs
difficultés
grâce à cette méthode que j'avais
apprises et que j'ai perfectionné
il y avait tellement de bons résultats
que je voulais donc d'autres en
profitent
je ne pouvais pas m'occuper de tout le
monde alors j'ai créé une entreprise ope
way ning pour pouvoir former des parents
et des professionnels des outils
performants et est conçu pour développer
les fonctions cognitives et processus
nécessaires à l'apprentissage ont été
précisés notre manière d'enseigner
s'appelle la méta pédagogie c'est une
démarche transversale aux pédagogies
hésitante elle s'applique à tout le
monde même aux personnes qui n'ont pas
de handicap
je me souvenais que nicolas avait des
difficultés pour apprendre à écrire et
alors nous avons conçu des applications
pour tablettes pour apprendre à tracer
des traits de bases de l'écriture puis
les lettres tout en s'amusant
nicolas avait aussi d'élus des soucis
pour apprendre reconnaître gérer ses
émotions
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec j'ai
conçu des outils pour reconnaître
comprendre et gérer les émotions pour
que d'autres c'est puissent en profiter
mais l'intelligence émotionnelle ne fait
pas seulement référence aux émotions
elle s'intéresse aussi à la capacité à
communiquer de la meilleure façon
possible
et dans ce domaine beaucoup de personnes
avec autisme ont des difficultés ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'on n'a pas
besoin d' autisme pour avoir des
difficultés à communiquer dans notre
foyer
nicolas ne supportait pas les disputes
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
nous avons appris à communiquer sans
disputes et j'ai créé des outils pour
apprendre à communiquer et gérer les
conflits
grâce à cette expérience avec mon fils
j'ai pu apprendre créer et aider les
autres
nicolas aime la comptabilité travailler
sur ordinateur joue au piano ce qui est
vert de l'équitation et apprendre à
connaître les autres on ne choisit
peut-être pas ce qui nous arrive mais on
peut choisir de se comporter
soit comme une victime en attendant
passivement que cela vienne soit d'être
proactif et agir
c'est notre choix nous pouvons le faire
pour chaque expérience nous pouvons agir
trouver des moyens et apprendre quelque
chose grâce à nicolas et ses frères et
soeurs ma vie est devenue passionnante
alors d'un handicap qu'est ce que je
vais faire avec
je dis oui et merci
[Applaudissements]